job fairs job openings now hiring signs
all indications we're moving closer to
100 percent capacity in a little over a
month
and 80 percent by next weekend good
evening thanks for joining us at six
i'm brian loftis and i'm denise valdez
while there are
hundreds of jobs available there may not
be hundreds of people to hire
and that's the problem a lot of
businesses owners are now facing
joe muller stopped by a few places
looking for new employees he's live near
south buffalo in the 215 tonight
brian and denise this is frustrating for
many business owners they are welcoming
this uh
more business but they want to make sure
they can keep up with the demand and get
some employees in the doors this is
fruits and roots
it's a juice bar they need workers not
only here but they
soon to open new location
i'm pretty sure a lot of people can
attest to how difficult it was once
coveted hit
as businesses like fruits and roots
start picking up the races on to bring
on more employees
we're open to new hires that are wanting
to come through and apply and work with
us
operations manager nate guerrero is
preparing to open a second location
as more places look to hire and larger
companies host job fairs
adding employees is easier said than
done it's been a difficult time
uh hiring i would say at least 75
if not more percent of people that we've
kind of reached out to
and indeed instagram facebook all the
platforms
have not showed yeah so it's been crazy
fruits and roots is not the only
business having a difficult time finding
people i mean there are a lot of jobs
out there
it's you know especially us we're
looking for servers we're looking for
managers
we're looking for busser ignazio sessa
owns the omelette house in summerlin and
sky canyon we're taking applications you
know
we're doing a lot of ads on the review
journal and stuff like that but
it's we haven't been getting no bites
it's been tough i mean
but a year ago a year and a half ago i
would put something on
craigslist for servers i mean i'd have
to swap
he believes some are opting to stay on
unemployment as the pandemic continues
he knows many other business owners are
in the same boat i got
like four or five guys that are in the
same industry that i'm at and they're
struggling too
what i'm doing but you know what we're
just we just got to hold on
now back out here live dieter in the
past has announced that they are going
to return the work search requirement
for unemployment claimants
that is going to start on may 1st
reporting live at buffalo on the 215 joe
mohler 8 news now